ескізи іспанського дизайнера Гудман дурою
аронсона
наріжте на подіумі його модний показ
ikea вику зумієш наука ви фантастики то
п'ятничного місця ці жму дизайнер
експерименту я в одну зараз порушуючу
зупиняє канонами з цілою модою
віджиму до в ісландії що дуже багато
молюся а 20 вісімковий аронсон обидві
cs100 ти дірку і наодинці босх або ngc
інструмент життя тут на духу та
з правді екзотика можливо це моя 1 ніби
і сланцем і ось але година екзоту на
standing on the edge of thick біля річки
віку
столиця ісландії з поїдання до їжі
ліберж і творчість нашій справі
пустували дизайн матч свої роботи
представляє 350 дизайнерів з батчат і
їх прийшли близько 30000 виду їжу на що
самої ж 10 сотки населення країни
фаршу фестиваль вигляду всі 2009 року top
to review zarik з готової від на неї
через святого фінансового пацюка у
сподобалося і на матчі банкрутство по
приз круто фестиваль організований та
іспанським центром дизайну зумі стати і
на новий а щур то проводжають петрівною
точку та розвитку національні креативної
економіки неп файз з акселя факт це
щур вийняв на рожевий топ дизайну за
рахунок того щоб анкери про ці-то
проти лякав і тих хто постраждав ще
раз круто змінив і спеціалізацію на що
із бірж креативні ставте таємниць зі мною
моя квартира за так їх обставлений бичків
творить і їх under your own song 2012
лінза знову владні марку одягу your
shoes народившись на початку речах костюмах
класичного крою
його клієнти про важливу наземки процесор
від ісландії до дали більше підтягнув
watcha міс цілого дизайну
я по металу щурів змінила сталлоні
людей цілому ти шлях і залишити вона геть
і по людині привід та менеджери j овочів
а кістки і до гаю кольору шкіри стояв біля
розгадку msc по дизайну з опіками обличчя
криється порожнечі санвузол з chordin лейбл
ви лікар або такого тренду вик прийом
стокер ви створи його дизайну популярні на
адже у далекі японії за нову
інтерпретацію звичайно рибальська шапки
2014 року он і утри малий на цунамі
дизайнерський нам роду gerl він відтепер
ослу буде національний міф це легендою
ягід для тіла схожого на ворона польшу
ось для комбінезону що на році я до
слову та стату та тонкого laune з тренд
писай на в ісландії
дизайн не медові історії на відьомку
вигляд у снують ось 6 то літератури теж ми
подумали що вард порубає і їх під
ґрунтом нашу і творчо ми просто
робили давню історію у наших виборів і
this ain't come from дати розрубаний і
дизайнерам і моделі висновок
трикотажної фабрики гравці омегу за
ставить сотку ви ісландську і хвилі
шекель до руки в думу вирубні 100
балоном і зуб інгео т.п.
завдяки молодим дизайнерам проживаючи
відродження
дай сюди гіс ландіка шерсть
над завершуючи але важливий матеріал у нашому
кліматі
просто на orchid на мати і окисні о
днями можна боспорі бяньші не сказати і
безводні з lanten а ви скарг про суму
wanna take багатого означаючи для нашої
культури altea
дизайнерський бум вдихнув в інший жити
і у ситих і портовий район рейк'явіка
цибулі лижник складських приміщеннях творче
люди вигляд крила свої ательє щі кілька
місяців тому тут було шкіряна майстерня
а нині студія прикрас арифін гурт
дизайн рифу своїй роботі натикаєшся
старими інструментами та традиційними
морськими з символами я кіт якорем формі
айсан так і пдк газу для ісландців якір
травня велике значення видаляється на рік я
нам про наше горе мені та ми пощастили низький
і а нам би живим про на острові я here
символ зуя наш культурний спадом курсі
відріжте
наші предки були рибалка ми-то морякам і
і ти твої фішман рушницею одне
are crying for sellers
2015 дизайнерам руку в ісландії стала
елду роман
ягуна творчості відпочив і міс цілий
фольклор to my stats змін
культурно врятуй нас правді увійшла в моду
в Україні